look at this ah it's beautiful
i like this one the door one dog goes
one way and the other dog goes the other
way have you ever noticed how many
movies poke fun at art
took me like three hours to finish the
shading on your upper lip
lots of movies make fun of art and the
artist especially highbrow contemporary
art there's that age-old gag where
someone confuses an everyday object for
a modern work of art criticism of
contemporary art does make sense
since it's so much more interpretive and
high concept when compared to a typical
movie when people try to interpret
modern abstract art it often feels like
they're just making it up honeymoon
and that's one of the many reasons why
this scene in goodfellas is so hilarious
he doesn't attempt some
pseudo-intellectual criticism he just
describes what's in the painting but
when it comes to movies poking fun at
art and art criticism
there is a bit of a contradiction going
on here right in betelgeuse nobody takes
delays sculptures seriously and the
bizarre house remodeling gets played for
laughs
i know just as much about the
supernatural as i do about interior
design
but both the sculptures and the house
fit the aesthetic of the overall film
in a way the film is making fun of not
just the characters taste
but also the over-the-top style of the
film itself there's a sort of meta
self-deprecation going on here
a film like parasite will make fun of
over analyzing art but also invite the
viewer to do the exact same thing
in the movie itself
whether intentional or not making fun of
contemporary art within a contemporary
film exposes a crucial element of
filmmaking
when it comes to making movies the
people making them are a little biased
of course filmmakers aren't going to be
interested in abstract art because
they've devoted their lives to working
in perhaps the most populous
art form there is movies
you want to go to the movies yep every
movie has one thing in common
they're made by people who make movies
let's see how this obvious yet
overlooked idea might add a fresh new
understanding to some classic films and
give us insight into the limitations of
film itself
[Applause]
how's everybody going in 1992 snl ran a
sketch that made fun of old school
observational comedy
here's our opening question what's the
deal with airplane food
and now decades later what's the deal
with airplane food has remained an
iconic phrase that people use to make
fun of stand-up comedy cliches you know
what don't get no respect
airplane food i think this phrase has
remained relevant because
to this day pretty much every single
comedian at some point in their career
has made a joke about air travel
i'm sure your favorite comedian has done
it at least once it's such a popular
topic that the laugh factory youtube
channel even has its own compilation of
comedians just making airline jokes
so why is that is there something about
air travel that's just universally funny
or does the frequency of those jokes
have more to do with the comedians
themselves
think about it if you're a working
comedian and there isn't a global
pandemic going on your life consists of
flying around to different cities to
perform stand-up
a comedian's job depends on air travel
so when they make jokes about it they're
sticking to what they know
and filmmakers do the same thing in the
form of the film within a film genre
[Applause]
the film within a film genre contains
movies about writing and directing
movies
like a comedian constantly flying a
filmmaker is constantly working to get a
movie made
so a movie about that process is
sticking to what they know
the genre has been popular since the
beginning of hollywood one of the more
recent examples is menk
a movie about writing the screenplay for
the movie citizen kane which itself has
a film within a film in the form of a
documentary about charles foster kane
and citizen kane is itself a movie all
about different forms of mass media
including filmmaking theater and
journalism just like many other
critically acclaimed films
of the last 10 best picture winners six
prominently feature movies
television theater or journalism and
that's no coincidence
it makes sense that oscar voters would
vote for movies about industries they
participate in
and it makes sense that filmmakers would
gravitate to telling stories they're
inherently familiar with
on the surface it does seem somewhat
uninspiring that a screenwriter would
just write a story about their own job
many of these films have the exact same
tropes like the writer dealing with
writer's block or the struggle over
whether or not to have a happy ending
but like any genre filmmakers have found
ways to experiment with this formula
in barton fink a playwright moves to
hollywood to write a screenplay
the film has the classic film within a
film tropes but it uses them in a unique
way
fink claims to want to write about the
common man yet he ignores his neighbor
who happens to know exactly what he
needs
as roger eber pointed out the film could
be read as an analogy to the rise of
fascism in europe the film takes place
at the start of world war
ii and fink a jewish leftist
intellectual ignores the appeal of
fascism to the common man until it's too
late
the film is intentionally ambiguous
enough to not have such a clear-cut
interpretation but regardless the
surprising twists and turns of barton
fink
show how a film about writing a
screenplay can be about much more than
the screenplay
itself martin fink shows that the
filmmaking process can represent
different ideas but more
films actually do the reverse they don't
use filmmaking as a metaphor for
something else
they use something else as a metaphor
for filmmaking take parasite which is
not about making movies or about the
entertainment industry but about a poor
family trying to scheme their way into
jobs working for a wealthier family
in perhaps the most well-known segment
of the film we see the filmmaker's bias
break through
the elaborate execution of the peach
fuzz heist requires perfect acting
choreography and direction
in other words the kim family puts on a
performance they even use the same
language a director
the film has nothing to do with cinema
directly yet the characters act like
filmmakers to show who's in control
in this sequence the family directs the
heist so the camera follows their
movements precisely
it's only later in the film when their
plan begins to unravel that the camera
follows behind
them unable to see what will happen next
and later other people become the
directors of the family's movement
it makes sense that a film director
would use something like control of the
camera to represent a character being in
control because that's precisely how a
film director's control plays out on a
film set
even set pieces in parasite contain
elements of filmmaking
bong joon ho said they purposefully
built the giant glass window in
cinemascope ratio to make it feel like
the characters are watching a film
screen
making this window so cinematic further
contrasts it with the very
uncinematic windows in the
semi-underground department when people
call things
cinematic they're describing moments
that feel perfectly suited for cinema
and what's more suited for cinema than
these film within a film moments where
the movie pushes the art form to its
limits and we can feel the presence of
the movie makers themselves
the thing about there will be blood um
there was really no cinematic
set pieces in the movie well then i saw
the film again and i was completely
wrong that the
putting out of the the oil fire is
absolutely positively a set piece it's a
brilliant cinematic set piece this scene
in there will be blood feels so
cinematic in part because
like parasite it has elements of a film
within a film
look at how daniel plainview moves his
arms in this shot to direct his crew to
add explosives to the fire he might as
well be saying
action throughout the film plainview
fulfills the role of a director or a
producer like a producer he has to seek
out funding for his project
and like a director he manages the
construction of his set and gives orders
to his
crew eli sunday is another director he
literally directs a congregation
and he serves as the main antagonist in
the film because he challenges the
directorial authority of plane view
notice how throughout the film whichever
character is in control is the one
directing the other character
once you start looking for these film
within a film moments you start to see
them
everywhere consider one of the most
cinematic films of all time
2001 a space odyssey the monolith went
through several designs before kubrick
settled on the iconic black slab is
it a coincidence that like the window in
parasite the monolith is the same shape
as a film screen
and we get this shot where the monolith
literally becomes the screen we're
watching
not only that but how is the shape of
the other most cinematic object a camera
maybe these were coincidences 2001 has
dozens of totally valid interpretations
but when you recognize that any
filmmaker's personal life revolves
around
filmmaking doesn't it make sense that
they would construct objects and plot
elements in their films based on what
they know
i'm not saying that all these filmmakers
intentionally tried to make a film
within a film but what i am saying is
like a comedian talking about air travel
a film set is full of people whose
profession is making movies so they will
inevitably bring that perspective into
their creative choices
that perspective also explains why
movies make fun of contemporary art
it's because it's a completely different
art form it's no surprise that the
populist medium of movies will disregard
the exclusive and pretentious art scene
and instead focus on characters and set
pieces that relate back to filmmaking
itself
when it comes to art artists tend to
express what they know and not just in
movies
authors like stephen king often write
about writers like in king's novels the
shining and misery but what makes
filmmaking stand out is that it's a
competitive highly specialized industry
full of nepotism
most successful filmmakers have to
devote their lives to their craft
as a result the people who make movies
tend to make a career out of it and that
means we'll always get the perspective
of that hard-working career filmmaker
the drawback to this phenomenon is that
we often get stuck with a particular
archetype
take lala land a film about a musician
and an actress the two main characters
are obsessed with trying to break into
their industries
to the point that they can't make time
for each other it's the classic
archetype of the down on their luck
artist devoting their lives to do what
they're destined to do
and that archetype doesn't just exist in
movies about artists
interstellar is about a mission in space
but the life of the main character feels
similar to the life of a director he's a
person called to perform his craft at
the expense of being unable to see his
family for long periods of time
because of the nature of being a devoted
artist we'll tend to get lots of grand
movies about fulfilling one's destiny
and less movies about how the vast
majority of people live their lives the
truth is most of life isn't cinematic
it's mostly just people trying to get by
that's why i'll always appreciate low
budget less
cinematic movies films like nomad land
and moonlight don't revolve around
people trying to make
it the films instead find the beauty and
tragedy in everyday living
and yet even those movies have cinematic
moments every movie is the same because
every movie is made by people who make
movies that sounds extremely obvious and
meaningless at first but understanding
that
reality is absolutely crucial to
understanding cinema as an art form
but you know another reason why every
movie is the same because you can enjoy
all of them without having to think
about any of this stuff i can watch
parasite and just think
i like this one one family goes one way
the other family goes the other way one
is going east and that's always going
west so what
when it comes to watching movies it's
important to branch out and see more
than just filmmaker-centric hollywood
movies and one way to do that is by
exploring documentary films
documentaries focus less on the typical
experience of a filmmaker and instead
explore fresh ideas that often have
nothing to do with filmmaking
my recent favorite is the documentary
pizza love story which like any great
movie changed how i thought about things
in this case it made me appreciate pizza
even more than i already did
you can watch that documentary and
thousands more by signing up for
curiosity stream
curiosity stream is all about big budget
non-fiction videos and if you sign up
for curiosity stream with the link in
the description
you get access to curiosity stream and
nebula the streaming service that
supports exclusive ad-free videos from
youtube's top
education creators including yours truly
you can get this incredible deal for
less than fifteen dollars a year just
fifteen dollars for an entire year
all you have to do is click that link in
the description clicking that link is a
great way to show your support for this
channel and for high quality educational
content online
thanks to curiositystream for sponsoring
this video and thank you to my lovely
lovely patreon supporters i love you all
you